know this that wasn't the right guy that
was the wrong guy you want to scare off
the wrong guys faster to attract the
right guy faster the right guy is going
to understand the right guy is going to
be patient I was just coaching a woman
in our manifest your man coaching
program oh no
manifest that's the third buzz word now
I just want to talk to the girls for a
second they like two women that watch
me when a guy says these Buzz terms
which typically means they're pandering
or they had a domineering mother and
they never really were around like guys
like that a lot of the time just my two
cents and I'll tell you one thing
journey is one of them manifest if a guy
says manifest you just got to run what
up guys welcome to the just perly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I have a special
guest on the channel welcome our newest
Talent Choy thank you very much Paul
good to be here thanks for thanks for
coming so today we're going to be re
reacting to some male dating coaches and
I want you to tell me if this is good
advice or bad advice today so five nice
girl habits that all women must
eliminate now so when you think of a
nice girl what do you think of sweet
submissive does stuff for the guy is not
is not doesn't get
confrontational what do you think is the
problem women I I often hear women say
that I was too nice I gave too much what
do you think is the problem they were
probably targeting the wrong dude to be
honest like if because if the guy is is
high value he's got options in the
dating Marketplace then it kind of It
kind of doesn't matter uh in a way the
stuff that she does he may still go
elsewhere right you know so you can't
really get around the variety problem so
I think they may be targeting the wrong
dudes okay let's let's see but he's
saying there's habits that we got to
eliminate I want let's see see your
blind spots blind spots trip us up on
our journey of love because the blind
spots by definition I hate it when guys
say journey journey of love it's even
worse cuz journey is cringe and then
it's like a journey of love it's like a
women thing I'm going on my journey
can't see what they are we can't fix
them if we're not aware of what they're
doing let's talk about some of the
habits that we have that are actually
blind spots that could be sabotaging you
trying to attract the love that you want
on a call recently I had a client bring
up she was like what are the blind spots
that I have how do I know what I'm doing
that's working versus what's sabotaging
me and the challenge is so many women
that I coach are probably just like you
in the sense that you're openhearted you
want to lead your life with generosity
and kindness you're a giver and if
that's naturally how you are there might
be some blind spots that you have when
you're dating that you think are leading
with generosity kindness love but are
actually backfiring because they fall
under this what we call this nice girl
we're calling these the nice nice girl
habits that really at the end of the day
aren't nice for you or him or your love
life and what they are actually doing is
steering your love life into a
[Laughter]
ditch it's a bit like my love so today
we're going to look
[Music]
at I'm only joking and how to shift them
so that you can accelerate the rate at
which you attract love into your life so
the first pattern or that you want to
take a look at is if you cancel plans
with your friends to accommodate his
last minute invitation now there might
be part of you that's saying like what
like I'm just being easygoing right I'm
just being go with the flow men love
that I want someone who's easygoing and
going with the flow now be clear we're
not talking about you not having plans
and just kind of hanging out and it
totally fits within your schedule this
scenario is cancelling plans that you've
made with friends to go out with him I
mean I get where he's coming from
because what he's basically saying is be
in your own frame right don't just roll
over and just do whatever the dude want
wants to do and there is some value in
that because I think if a woman is too
needy like it's like the same thing with
nice guys you know I think if the woman
is too needy and she is too available
that can be that can be a little bit
offputting but I don't think this is a
deal breaker really I don't think this
is such a big deal as he's making it
really I mean you know it's kind of like
and sometimes probably you do want to
cancel those plans if he's like Hey
listen bab how good are your friends as
a woman I mean I mean if he's like hey
babe listen i' you know I've got going
to this amazing event tonight you're
going to come down she's like no I'm
with my friend you know it's like it's
it's he's not going to think oh yeah
she's so she's so in her frame I really
want her more he's just going to think
oh annoying can't he cancel what are you
doing I was like do do the guys even
like think about what you're doing that
like no I I don't really think they do
and again if he's a high value dude he's
he's in demand let's say yeah the kind
of guy that a lot of women obviously
want to be with right he might just be
like all right well she's not available
let's get someone else in things are at
work with this Dynamic number one you're
impeding your relationship with your
friends because you're teaching your
friends that when something better comes
along you're going to cancel on them for
that better opportunity and that does
not Foster deeper relationships the
second thing that we want to pay
attention to is you're teaching this guy
that you're dating that his needs and
wants Trump your own his plans are more
important than your plans and so you're
that might not be a bad thing though
actually I was just thinking like that
could actually be a good thing to be
honest I mean you don't like I don't
know man I mean for me it's it's sort of
it's Nuance cuz to some extent cuz I
don't want somebody who's a complete
walkover but at the same time really you
want them to be on your team right yeah
you know and if you call up and like hey
there's this really cool thing we can do
tonight like yeah yeah sure I'll I I'll
come over you know like you want that
don't you forcing his behavior to hey I
can send an invite out to this woman
last minute and she'll be available
you're not teaching him to give you ADV
advaned notice and to send you plans
where you know what to expect and you
can actually schedule it in the second
pattern that you want to shift is
allowing him to play insult you even
though deep down it hurts your feelings
now often this comes in the spirit of
hey we want to be easygoing I don't want
to be so sensitive I want to be able to
be playful and be fun and be flirty but
if the way that he's playing if the way
that he's B well then you're never going
to end because women are offended by
everything if if the bar is what offends
you it's like I'm sorry I've interviewed
too many chicks I just I can't I mean
what what are the guys you guys are
dating saying to you that's so offensive
like that's my question maybe he'll give
me an example with you or being flirty
with you comes with little insults that
ultimately leave you feeling down or
leave you feeling hurt or sad or
whatever it is then you want to speak up
and you want to maintain your boundaries
you see bound boundaries there you go
he's he's had two buzzwords already has
any journey and boundaries it's like on
the Pearl bingo card of like oh no no no
aular he's going to say trauma in a
minute no boundaries don't push people
away boundaries actually create
closeness think about that why would
that really I'm sorry I just have never
seen a woman say boundaries and the
relationship get better I I don't guys I
just in my experience I just yeah I've
never I've never seen that like go well
have you no okay so you're a bit older
than me maybe you have because when
you're sharing with somebody your
boundaries you're sharing with them
vulnerably here's what feels good to me
and here's what doesn't here's where my
line is as far as how to treat each
other and when he knows that about you
he knows you even deeper a time that I
learned this in a very very powerful way
with my girlfriend at the time who was
now my wife is I grew up in a family
where we teased and we rough house there
was a lot of physical wrestling and
playing and that was just part of what
we thought was fun and so we go to Olive
a garden for one of these dates and uh
on our way out of Olive Garden we're
kind of teasing and bantering and having
fun and you know using our words and
then on the way walking out of the doors
I kind of like kick jump to the side and
I kick and I kick her in the butt and I
think that's really fun like that's a
way we could play together yeah she was
not having it and she stopped it right
there she was like oh no you didn't I do
not play like that I don't want that I
don't accept that never kick me in the
butt like that again and I was like okay
I get it got get the message now she
could have maybe been a little bit
softer in her approach but needless to
say it was highly effective I knew where
the line was to me this says that his
wife is making the rules in his
relationship and he's following probably
yeah I mean like it doesn't sound bad
what he did you know he was messing
around he was kind of playing and she
basically came in and said no you know
probably in an over dramatic way and
then he's like all right okay so I I'll
just go along with that okay fine I
think that women use offense as a way to
control men I don't really think they're
offended half the time I think they just
like to use it to control man or me
sorry no because sometimes these
chicks like they get so offended and I'm
like you can't actually be offended oh
what they're pret because they're like a
tweet or something they like oh my God
that's so offensive but I think actually
you're right I think a lot of people
they talk up this offensive thing now
and who's really offended it's like are
you are you actually I don't know I knew
where the boundary was and I respected
her for owning her boundary setting her
standard for how we want to play
together so if you notice that he's
playing or flirting or having fun in a
way that doesn't feel good to you not
saying anything actually creates
distance between the two of you saying
something holding your boundary that's
what creates closeness the third habit
that you want to really be careful of is
changing your personality to fit his
mood and this comes from the
kind-hearted part of ourselves where we
want people to feel comfortable we want
them to feel good around us but the
challenge is if you're shifting your
personality because they're unhappy or
it's going to make them feel better then
you're actually compromising your way of
being in the world isn't it better to do
that though because if you're a
supportive partner isn't it better to
make the person feel happy particularly
if you're a you're a woman you know
you're with this high value guy it's
like surely the role that you want to
play
feel good I would think the same thing
but I don't know sometimes these guys
talk and I'm like oh your wife has to
run the
relationship you're what like I know I
just like hear it in their voice and
typically they they're used to it
because they have a domineering mother
typically well I mean M I mean Matt BS I
mean he looks like he's probably under
the thumb isn't he probably at the end
of this video be like Matt Matt where
are you it's dinner time great
relationships were both people can
coexist and really be themselves you've
got a particular personality this unique
to you and you want to let it yeah but
men change for women all the time they
make more money they get in better shap
and I'm not saying like they they should
or they shouldn't but my point is they
men adjust to what women want in order
to get women but women are not expected
to adjust for what men want in order to
get men and it's interesting because in
this video he just said the man should
adjust his behavior for you with a
boundary but you should not adjust your
behavior for him you you catch that and
you want express it you want to be the
fullness of yourself and chances are
there have been times in your life I
know there's been times in mine where we
are around people whether it's teachers
or whether it's parents or whether it's
the people taking care of us that are
telling us not to express ourselves
you're being too loud sit down be quiet
you're disturbing other people so on and
so forth and so we learn to mute
ourselves to dial ourselves down as
children maybe you've been in a
relationship where I can like hear the
women saying that he wanted wanted me to
be less you have you heard that like
women complain about that what was that
like women will always say oh he like
was holding me back he wanted me to be
less when it's like really we're just
doing some stuff that's annoying and
they tell us to stop yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah well any anything could be sort of
turned around and be made to look sort
of abusive or semi- abusive or kind of
like oh you were repressing my feminine
wonderful beautiful feminine energy and
it's like well maybe you were just like
annoying talking too loud and the person
you're with is like you are really over
the top right now like you need to bring
it down and so you mute yourself you
dial yourself down or you have a
particular laugh or when you really love
something you laugh and you're big and
the person's like yeah never laugh like
that again like she it just sounds like
this imaginary person is just an
annoying
doesn't yeah I mean maybe you have an
annoying amazed at what people do to try
to create control in relationships you
really want to watch he just said you
could control him by getting offended by
the butt kicking and that you have to
show your boundaries I always noticed
it's always like the women can control
the men but the men can't control the
women what he interesting with this
isn't it because obviously this is a
dude speaking who got a male dating
coach but he's obviously talking to a
female audience which is one thing he's
got a panda to them and secondly he's
probably under the thumb himself anyway
so you got the you know the double
whammy of I think some guys just have
like a naturally like they've just been
red by domineering mothers so their mind
almost goes to like the feminine way of
thinking weirdly well it's the default
sort of oh the woman is right the woman
should always be the you know the
predominant one all that my default is
the woman is wrong the woman is always
wrong person really just asking for a
need they have or are they trying to
control you and your personality cuz
what you want is someone who's willing
to unleash you to this world let me give
you an example of how if you stay in an
environment that doesn't support who you
really are how it can begin to eat away
at your happiness and and your own
self-esteem there was a phase where I
had to shift my personality to have the
success that I wanted you see I'm a
naturally very big energy guy like I
love to have fun I love to laugh I'm
really animated I bring the energy
probably
why bringing this content to you this
has gone so big because of that kind of
energy in my early 20s I had a job as a
time share salesperson down in Mexico
and in sales my energy being real big
and enthus I Astic like that was working
against me like I wasn't selling wasn't
selling wasn't selling and my mentor at
the time told me Matt you really got to
tone it down like dial yourself you're
at a 10 right now you need to be at a
two be quiet don't say much really just
sit back kind of let them do all the
talking and like you just put on a he's
like put on a personality where you're
super shy and so I was like well I'm not
selling anything anyway let me try that
and so I did I put on this like really
shy personality and I was like acting
like I was shy like I was really timid
and and it was crazy it worked and I
started selling like Gang Busters and so
when I would get to work I'd put on this
personality of shy and timid shy and
timid shy and timid and I was making all
this money and selling but then
something crazy started to happen
outside of work I noticed that my
personality was beginning to shift
outside of work I found myself more shy
more timid outside of work I found
myself less happy
less myself because I was betraying
myself I started to fall into this
depression even though I was selling I
was feeling more and more sad because
ultimately when you betray yourself your
levels of happiness plummet and so I
realized I've got to shift you know what
that means well there's the problem with
all of this is right it's it's kind of
an argument for people to leave
relationships and marriages isn't it
because what he's basically saying is oh
If he if he kind of contains you in any
way then you deserve better than that
because you deserve to be Unleashed or
whatever his word was right and so you
know and we we we're in this culture
where people just walk out of marriages
the whole time don't they and you know
so some wom's going to be like yeah he
told me not to laugh once all right you
know and it's kind of that women should
be contained and men shouldn't be
contain no seriously because when we're
left to our own devices I just don't
know how you can't you can argue that
it's like going well well I mean women
used to always be more contained didn't
they I mean that was the vict thing it's
like no the you know the wife of the
children be quiet you know the man will
you know to put a a nuzzle over bring
back the
muzzle that new t-shirt like yeah bring
put the mule I mean guys what it be the
War I mean I was thinking about it I was
like I mean sometimes it' probably be
good for us we'd get like our our nose
breathing like Hannibal lecta kind of
mask you know like got to get out of
this and into something that I was born
to do which is to teach and mentor and
coach and so I launched my coaching
business and left and lo and behold my
natural personality is a perfect fit for
what I'm called to do here's the point
your natural personality is a perfect
fit for your perfect partner if someone
doesn't like the way you laugh if
someone doesn't love the way you are
when is who you are your natural
personality I have met a lot of women
their natural personality is not for
anybody got to be honest with you
they're argumentative they're overweight
they can never be wrong there's some
women that are like okay you can work
with it but I mean don't we all have to
shift our personality a bit in different
environments though right I mean he's he
say it like it's this terrible thing but
actually that's kind of the nature of
say a work environment or oh yeah
Corporate America you know or I mean
there's there's lots of times when we
have to put on a slightly different
personality I don't think it's the end
of the world you know are not the right
fit for you shine your authentic light
and let those who are meant to be with
you come your way now the fourth habit
that you want to eliminate is allowing
yourselves to get physical or sexual
before you're comfortable you see
there's this my don't like that one huh
well I mean I don't know man I mean I
mean like attraction is the glue that
like holds relationships together and
sex sex and intimacy right that is the
kind of the key thing really and and
it's I mean let's see what he says but
it sounds like he's sort saying oh you
got to really get to know them and blah
blah blah but actually if you really get
to know them you could like all of that
energy could be gone you know you end up
friend zoning each other whatever and
second the whole basis of this is that
it's a sexual romantic thing right it's
a relationship so why not just cut to
the chase but yeah it also depends on
the age of the women in my opinion
because I mean that might make more
sense when a girl's like okay a teenager
but it's like over a certain like ladies
ladies I just say this is kind of how
men view it over a certain age they're
kind of like what are we waiting for
you're not a
virgin exact like feel like you know
like you're 30 what are we waiting for
yeah exactly I mean it was like you know
the conversation about when should a
woman sleep with a guy and I mean we can
obviously you know I can probably do
some more content on that at another
time but I mean the reality is you don't
want to be waiting around for too long
you you probably want to make him wait
for like one day or something like that
just to you know put some anticipation
in there but you don't want to be
holding it out forever because it's it's
almost a little bit kind of like well
what are we play what are we messing
around at you know like what's going on
here you know yeah I agree if you don't
have sex when he wants to have sex then
you're GNA possibly lose this great guy
and it's actually the opposite that's
true you see sex doesn't create
closeness for men men don't equate sex
with emotional connection
well they don't I suppose but I mean men
do want sex and so if you're not
providing that or you're sort of you
seem to be sort of holding out for some
reason there is a chance you'll lose it
cuz he might just go into someone else
yeah I'll tell you what I think that
works on younger guys I think men under
the age of 25 roughly that'll work on
where they're like the game playing or
whatever but there's a certain age where
just men seem to kind of figure out that
all women are the same yeah and then and
then you're just like yeah whatever and
there's no special and you can tell the
men that got married before they figured
this
out because they kind of still have this
like the way they describe their wives
is not very human but it's almost like
goddess like yeah like like the way they
describe her I'm like are you damn near
this woman is Jesus Christ like second
nothing against their wives I'm sure
they're lovely but they're still women
we're still human just like guys are
still there's things you could say about
guys where it's like okay your husband's
great but he's still a guy she's still a
woman and so I I find that men over a
certain age it's just not going to work
anymore I find game playing works less
on me now because for a start there's
the there's kind of Mystique about sex
isn't there when you're young when you
haven't had much of it and you're like
oh God it's this amazing thing and I'm
prepared to wait and all that and then
you get you know after a few rounds
you're you know you're just like well
whatever okay f
two things don't go in hand in hand now
I will say and this is where the
confusion comes in that once the two of
you are committed to each other in other
words you're committed to Growing the
relationship you're exclusive with one
another you've decided you're going to
be partners with one another doesn't
have to be married but it does need to
be this level of commitment yeah what do
you think about that well I wouldn't
like is he saying that you should wait
until there's a commitment before you
have sex no I think that's wrong because
you want to see if there's sexual
chemistry compatibility there before you
make the commitment you don't to be
committing to somebody first and then
like oh actually this is it's so
funny you're going to be the opposite of
all female doing
good no no but we are in 2023 that's the
case then sex does create closeness and
more emotional connection in a man now
know this if there's at all the fear or
the thought that well if I make him wait
he might not want to be with me he might
get impatient he might go choose
somebody else know this that wasn't the
right guy that was the wrong guy you
want to scare off the wrong guys faster
to attract the right guy faster the
right guy is going to understand the
right guy is going to be patient I was
just coaching a woman in our manifest
your man coaching program oh no
manifest that's the third buzzword now I
just want to talk to the girls for a
second the like two women that watch
me when a guy says these Buzz terms it
just it's all like feminist propaganda
and I don't really know how to EXP
explain how you know but there's certain
things that men say that to me indicate
they're always thinking from the female
point of view which typically means
they're pandering or they had a
domineering mother and they never really
were around like guys like that a lot of
the time just my two cents and I'll tell
you one thing journey is one of them
manifest if a guy says manifest you just
got to run well he's H the chick crack
Supply isn't he when he's saying that I
mean and it's obviously again you know
you're pandering to a female audience
you last week and she was like it's so
weird as a girl before I was redpilled I
would never have noticed this stuff but
once you see it you like can't unsee the
pandering and then you start to get so
irritated like why are you P I hate
pandering they're like I I go equally as
hard on simp as idea in Pand would I
mean look without being rude to him bit
of a s yeah well but yeah because his
when I think of simpery I think it just
means the men are serving the women
instead of the women serving the men so
so his whole thing talks about how the
men should serve the women he needs to
wait for you he needs to if you have a
boundary he needs to listen like it's
almost like they're like treating a guy
like a dog like you need to train him
but that's not how relationships don't
work cuz we're just not going to be
attracted to it well that is the problem
that's the fundamental problem with all
of this stuff and you know other videos
we've looked at it's like um they come
at it from this angle of like you've
just got to be the perfect gentle You'
got to be super do all these right
things but then women don't want that
well and that's the other problem too is
that we're all really confused because
as a girl you see some of this stuff
this this like the the games they play
on guys it works but it works on younger
guys or guys that are more simpy and the
problem is women will lose attraction to
the guys that it works on over time well
it's it's it's not going to work on a
guy who's got more options correct you
know because why why would he why would
he stand for well I'll give you an
example some sometimes it does like Will
Smith you don't think he had options no
okay like like same with Steve Harvey
you see these men in the media where
where it absolutely works on them but
it's because typically they have a
domineering or no dad like domineering
mother or no dad or you might say yeah
no fair point but you might say okay
he's obviously got options but he's
probably got what you might call a blue
pill mindset or he's got so corre
correct and so and so even if you get
into the relationship if the guy doesn't
get it if he doesn't you're you're going
to lose attraction or you're going to
lead the whole relationship for a
lifetime and that's what that's what I I
see a lot I see a lot of women
especially like the Christian it's
always like they're like oh I gave him a
chance what do you mean you gave your
husband a chance it's a very bad frame
for the for the guy to be in operating
it isn't it you know like he's begging
for a date with you why like you should
be begging with her I've watched a ton
of your videos I know how you always say
be willing to scare off the wrong guy to
attract the right guy and I was nervous
cuz we've been dating for a couple
months and we want to have sex but I'm
coule month Jesus what are they doing no
Miami I
like I'm just I'm just not comfortable
yet and he said the most beautiful thing
to me he said to me I'm totally willing
to go at your pace I want you to feel
fully comfortable I want you to feel
fully ready there's no rush why what but
just here's a question why are these
women holding out for so long because
presumably She's Dating the guy she must
feel you would think she feels some
attraction so what is the issue with her
not wanting to I don't think she's that
attracted to him I think that's the real
issue because want to they do especially
she's not a virgin right so it's like
that's probably why yeah cuz women
obviously women want to have sex we
sometimes you know women May well be
probably more sexual than men in some by
some measures I think this too but but
everyone always fights me I've never met
anyone that agrees with me well I I I
mean somebody made a good point the
other night didn't they on a show about
like testosterone and men are more
driven by testosterone which is sort of
like the sex drive hormon so you could
argue that but I think in terms of like
sensuality and sensual fantasy and all
this kind of stuff women are just
well if we counted women so I always
think of it like this if you okay pick
one you can have sex with hot women any
hot wom you want for the rest of your
life yeah or you get to look young the
rest of your life or would you pick have
sex okay most women would pick youth
right most women would pick looking
young over the sex what because they
because of their like narcissism no
because we value
attention we're turned on more by like
the guy like being attracted to us in a
way where the man it's more like the set
and so yeah and so if you look at who
desires what more I think women like if
you counted like receiving attention as
part of sexuality I think women get
naked like there's no tomorrow yeah
absolutely we love getting naked that's
like our favorite thing yeah absolutely
it's so weird isn't it the the whole
debate around objectification oh we get
objectified and stuff like that but I've
been that club we were talking about
before I mean you see ween parading
around wearing next to nothing and
clearly they they they're loving the
attention they're getting you know even
me on Twitter when I'm doing my em
challenge yeah that's why I always put
em this inappropriate but I always add
for a wife and a mother right right you
might want to show a little leg if
you're a single
yeah but but for the wife and a mother
I'm like why do married women want to be
naked so bad I saw this one chick and I
like her I felt that I think she was
offended her name's like nah and she's
like a UFC she's always doing and I
always see her posting these like half
naked pictures I find out she's got a
boyfriend of 10 years I'm like chica
what are you what are you I don't I like
I genuinely don't get why you would want
to post that stuff if you're in a
relationship or married you know doesn't
really make sense to me but you know
that's why I always say I think women
cheat more than men if you counted
flirting with other guys receiving
attention from other guys I think women
cheat way more way more yeah I mean if
you're counting that then 100% because I
mean any girl on Instagram Prett muches
like they felt like this whole sense of
Peace wash over me and then I realized
oh my gosh this is 100% oh my gosh this
going to wait for 6 months for me what
is that
boy wow on track with the right guy this
is the best relationship I've had but is
it the best relationship you've had if
you've been with this dude for how long
was it like like a like a decent amount
of time you haven't even wanted to sleep
with him or you haven't even like how is
that such a great relationship if you're
so reticent to get physical with someone
that that doesn't sound right yeah if
women it was a long time was it I've
seen things when women want to they will
it's just I get look I I get the point
you know some women are going to be more
conservative they're going to want to
wait a bit longer yeah fine okay I get
it and you don't have to you know but
come on I mean look I
mean like how old are these like they're
if they're like a teenage like that was
normal in like high school like people
would wait like there are people that
wait like years not do I mean allegedly
who knows but it but it becomes I was
talking to my friend James about this it
it becomes sort of awkward after a while
if you're if you're sort of dating a
woman for too long and you haven't done
anything it becomes a bit like what are
we actually doing here like what is this
you know yeah life and we're just two
months into this it was perfect evidence
mon two months and they haven't got
jiggy with it you're not you're upset
with that very upset
yeah well no look again you know I think
a bit of a bit of time fine but it it
just seems like what is I'm just really
fascinated with the psychology like why
is she holding out for that long if
she's kind of somewhat into this guy
like what is she waiting for you know
the right guy is 100% going to be on
your timeline with you and he will
respect that now I want to speak to the
part of you that if you're the type of
person where you're thinking Matt I just
want to have fun I'm in this casual I'm
in this sexual adventurous stage of my
life and I'm not yeah here we
go yeah yeah yeah right now now we're
talking now we're talking relationship I
want to just have fun the more power to
you this habit is saying yes before
you're comfortable bending your
standards to accommodate his needs
that's what you don't want to do what
you want to do is see but it's always
that he needs to wait for you whenever
you need to change for him I'm not even
arguing I mean don't sleep with someone
you don't want to sleep with it's just
awkward but it's just like after a point
in time what what are you doing yeah I
mean how much more do you need to get to
know him really I mean and and you can't
I think being physical with someone in
that in a sexual relationship is it's
part of the getting to know process
right I mean it's just you you know what
what else does she want to find out
after two months your horoscope can you
imagine and then can you imagine after
three months she finds out one thing and
she gets the ick and then the guy's like
no this is why why the red pill tells
these guys to spin plates ladies cuz
this is too much this is too much for
them oh they were talking about this on
a on a panel though actually that I was
on a while back and and basically that
there is the I'm not saying with this
woman because she's probably quite it
sounds like maybe quite conservative
whatever but there is the possibility if
if a woman's making a dude making a dude
wait for that long she may actually be
doing some other stuff behind you know
and kind of check check out her options
right oh like like she's actually
sleeping with no she's not sleeping with
him but she's sleeping with
some and let the guy raise his game to
the level of what you would love and
number five is forgiving him without
making an agreement for better behavior
for oh God ladies these these guys lead
us down the path of dis destruction
sometimes we are offended for no reason
okay I'm I'm going to say this I have
absolutely been mad for no reason and I
find out later that it was stupid
because our emotions ruin run our lives
that's just it guys are not dogs dogs
that you need to train like like look at
this he needs better Behavior like what
is he your kid just my point of view
just my point of view but yeah I just I
don't think you can control men I think
men are going to do what they're going
to do you either like it and stay or if
you don't like it then leave but I I
don't think this whole you're going to
well can you imagine if this was aimed
at guys and it was saying right you know
expecting better behavior from the woman
I mean it would just be like you just
get thrown off YouTube wouldn't you know
and he said in beginning that if he asks
you to change your personality that's a
negative but this is a positive yeah
yeah yeah this is necessary in
relationships we all make mistakes we
all screw up there's going to be a lot
of forgiving and healing in any kind of
Rel another I was just triggered I was
just triggered I was like oh no healing
yeah but what makes relationships work
is trust and trust is formed through
making and keeping agreements if he
screws up he hurts your feelings with
something that says or he doesn't show
up when he says he's going to show up or
he kicks your butt while walking out of
the Olive Garden and you state your
boundaries with
that you remember that
time if he just says he's sorry that's
not enough for fostering a really
healthy relationship and creating a new
outcome and we the what he got to do
like do penants or something like like
flate himself Penance I'm sorry I kicked
your butt in the Olive Garden it's like
oh thank you for saying you're sorry and
that's okay people say they're sorry
you're like oh that's okay that's the
wrong response to an apology a way
better response to an apology is when
someone says they're sorry you say thank
you and let's create a new agreement
moving forward he says he sorry yeah we
want relationships that are agreements
that doesn't sound very sexy does
it thank you for saying sorry for being
late and let's create a new agreement
when we make a time to be there we're
both going to be on time are you in for
that hey thank you for saying sorry for
kicking my butt on the way out of Olive
Garden and let's create a new agreement
that we're not what you guys did you
went to the car and said this is like on
the second date this is our new
agreement what's that I'm I'm saying did
he go with his wife and then on the
second date say is this our new
agreement honey fighting like that
because it doesn't feel good to me and
I'm like good that sounds great so
instead of saying it's okay and giving
him a pass on that behavior instead say
thank you and create a new agreement all
right all I can say I think that's
pretty much it yeah all I can say is
this is why us ladies are so
confused because relationships just I
just they do not work like this they do
not work when you were trying to train a
guy they do not work when you are making
him jump through hoops like all the
relationships that I've seen like that
just tend to end in destruction well so
here's an argument they might it might
work for a bit if the guy is super
submissive he's going to fall into her
frame right so Matt bogs is going to be
like okay I won't kick your butt in the
Rose Garden or whatever it was right but
is she going to be aroused by is she is
that a turn on for her or is she like oh
actually this guy's a bit of a s yeah
well it's still like an out of order
relationship so I see them like maybe
stay together and it's it's really
confusing if you're not redpilled
because you'll always hear them say oh
but they are married for so long you
don't know what you're talking about but
it's like until you see it you can't
unsee it and it's basically when you
look at a married couple and you look at
the guy's house it's decorated the exact
way that she wants it when they're
living they're living where she wants
like everything is on her terms when you
look at the out they had as many kids as
she wanted yeah and it's just like these
guys they almost become like a shell of
themselves over time yeah because
they're just trying to please a woman
and guys ladies you know we were never
happy but the aonic thing then is that
the woman generally starts to lose
attraction so women you know thinking
about this stuff you want to think okay
so what cuz generally speaking women are
kind of attracted to dominance they're
attracted to masculine qualities they
they want a guy to lead and stuff like
that but what will happen is over the
course of the relationship they slowly
erode that and so the guy's like
basically their lap dog and they like oh
hang on a minute he's not as hot he's
not as hot anymore you know it's kind of
like and then she divorces him and goes
on to the next one you know a personal
trainer that's what I heard exactly yeah
guys this is why we're confused but you
know um don't worry me and Troy are here
to help you out we're going to solve
this we're going to solve this
okay um Troy his link to his channel
will be in the description thank you for
coming on great to be here thank you
guys make sure you like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and ring the notification Bell and I
will talk to you next
time